some very interesting things happened
earlier this week pertaining to the
technosphere
and i shot a video about this a little
bit earlier yesterday actually
on this very subject but i wasn't quite
happy with it i wanted to tighten some
things up and re-shoot it
i think what's what's being put on the
table is very important and i want this
to to have a lot of
discussion and a lot of reflection and a
lot of engagement
so
i think there's going to be quite a few
points at which i'm going to sort of you
know do some hand waving and say i'll
talk about this or i'll talk about that
or i've talked about this or i've talked
about that in other videos because i
want to stay very uh very much on track
so there's going to be a lot of
reflections because i don't have when it
comes to these issues everything figured
out on my part or in fact
any
simple solutions
what this video is about is the reaction
earlier this week by two different
important sets of parties
to all the different revelations that
have been happening over the last oh
about six months even going back further
than that having to do with with data
gathering having to do with
nsa surveillance and surveillance by
other
intelligence agencies not all of which
are american
and
what happened earlier this week
was that on the one hand
some of the the giants of the
technosphere
some of the big corporations the ones
that are involved with with social media
or technology or providing the internet
or mobile service or name all of these
and wrap them all up in one
engage the president and congress with
an open letter
and i'll come back to that in a moment
on the other hand
independently of this
and in some ways antagonistic to what
was going on over here
about 500 writers
who i guess are fairly notable
you can actually see the list if you if
you look at the link that i'm going to
give you in the description
to the to the manifesto or declaration
or whatever you want to call it
issued a document that is titled a stand
for democracy in a digital age
and it says some really interesting
things not all of which i can actually
get behind some of which i'm as
suspicious about as i am about the
government or about corporations
um so i want to do a bit of reflecting
on this and a bit of uh
sort of you know deconstructing what's
going on here assumptions reading
between the lines
challenging you know raising some
questions that that you viewers might
find
uh interesting or engaging and things
that i don't have completely figured out
myself and i'm still thinking about
quite a bit
so what is the what is the the basic the
fundamental issue the catalyst for
getting all this going it's this issue
of information and who
gets to do what
with information
and
information is not just something about
us
information is also an act that we're
involved in we're giving off information
all of the time
whenever you're on facebook and you're
clicking like on something
especially if you go further than this
and like sign up for things on facebook
you are providing people with
information you are you're putting
information out there you may think that
it's only for your friends and family
but
probably most of my viewers don't think
this because i'm guessing that my
viewers are pretty savvy about social
media
it's not just for
the immediate audience
when you're writing emails i used to
tell my students this all the time
particularly when i was working in the
unc system
be very careful about what you say
because some emails may last forever may
come back later on to haunt you
when i was working in the unc system
north carolina actually had a law that
required all email exchanges an email
was the official means for communication
to be maintained in perpetuity
on these these servers i'm not sure
where they were located kind of an
interesting thought
because they were considered to be
essentially state property so
there's a lot of questions here about
who gets to do what with information and
with the manifesto or this this
declaration however we want to call it
there's a lot of uh discussion about the
the the difference between the private
and the public and and ownership of
information and
who gets to to access
what information and for what purposes
and with what effect so this is a very
uh interesting set of issues
so um let me talk first just a little
bit
about the the corporations and and their
involvement in this
so on monday they they gave this five
point letter or five principle letter
to
the government i mean it's an open
letter so it's really to everybody
they're they're addressing uh everybody
who who is possibly interested or
involved in this
and there's eight companies that got on
board with it it's funny that they start
out with aol they must oh i see they
they must have done this in in
alphabetical order because it's aol
apple
facebook google
linkedin microsoft twitter and yahoo
and it's kind of funny that they're
they're
putting the aol and yahoo at the two
ends the book ends because they're the
ones that are pretty dead in the water
for the most part um
apple facebook google microsoft those
are the big four i've talked about this
this issue of
uh platform plurality and and the the
tendency for these big four in
particular to get um
a sense of hubris and try to penetrate
into every aspect of
of uh our lives and try to take over
each other's territory
i i'll leave that aside because that's
an interesting issue that's worth
talking about in a further video
i find it very interesting that linkedin
and
twitter are also involved with this but
it makes perfect sense linkedin is the
premiere business networking um
social you know network platform
and there's a couple other things that
they're doing that are quite interesting
twitter is its own kind of animal
uh microblogging takes place there in a
way that's more dynamic than any other
place
and they are some of the really big ones
um it's interesting to see who's not
involved
in this
amazon for example
amazon didn't sign on to this i'm not
sure why
so what they say they're they're calling
for global government surveillance
reform and they say the undersigned
companies believe it is time for the
world's governments to address the
practices and laws regulating government
surveillance of individuals and access
to their information
and
they they believe that the current laws
and practices need to be reformed uh
consistent with established global norms
of free expression and privacy with the
goals of ensuring the government law
enforcement and intelligent efforts are
rule-bound
narrowly tailored transparent and
subject to oversight we hereby call upon
governments to endorse the following
principles and enact reforms that would
put these principles into action and the
principles are are pretty you know big
picture stuff limiting government's
authority to collect users information
is the first oversight and
accountability
transparency about government demands
respecting the free flow of information
and avoiding conflicts among governments
this is pretty big stuff and that that
i'm going to talk about in a separate
video because
if i were to get into that this would
sprawl into too many different issues
what i do want to point out before
moving on to the the writers
is that
this is this is the sort of stuff where
fault lines can be found
um
wanting them to or advising the
governments to avoid conflicts among
governments to be transparent about you
know their demands respecting the free
flow of information
this is big heady stuff and for these
major corporations who
whose moves and whose decisions play
such a big role in our lives in our
economy in our workplaces in our
educational institutions
to be taking this stand
this is a big step
now
i want to put all that aside and i want
to focus instead
on
the
the manifesto or declaration or you know
whatever you want to call it the list of
demands
the
op-ed piece whatever we want to to say
it is um the petition
and
this one is is written by a bunch of
ostensibly famous writers you can
actually go on to the site you can see
who they are it's indexed according to
first name last name and nationality i
have to admit i'm i'm not a very well
read person and i've never heard of most
of these people they they have very
little name recognition among me
among myself or or the set that i'm i'm
in and i suspect that um if you're kind
of a philistine
like me about contemporary culture
these names won't mean that much to you
but let's just take it for granted that
they are notable people what we would
call opinion formers
and i'll get to that you know why that
phrase is important in a moment
so what i've done is i've actually done
a little run through of the the document
i think it's very important to look at
the wording of it
so here
let's actually
focus on the text itself
in recent months the extent of mass
surveillance has become common knowledge
with a few clicks of the mouse the state
can access your mobile device your email
your social networking and internet
searches
it can follow your political leanings
and activities and in partnership with
internet corporations it collects and
stores your data and thus can predict
your consumption and behavior
the basic pillar of democracy is the
inviolable integrity of the individual
human integrity extends beyond the
physical body in their thoughts and in
their personal environments and
communications all humans have the right
to remain unobserved and unmolested
this fundamental human right has been
rendered null and void through abuse of
technological developments by states and
corporations for mass surveillance
purposes a person under surveillance is
no longer free a society under
surveillance is no longer a democracy to
maintain any validity our democratic
rights must apply in virtual as in real
space surveillance violates the private
sphere and compromises freedom of
thought and opinion
mass surveillance treats every citizen
as a potential suspect it overturns one
of our historical triumphs the
presumption of innocence
surveillance makes the individual
transparent while the state and the
corporation operate in secret as we have
seen this power is being systematically
abused surveillance is theft this data
is not public property it belongs to us
when it is used to predict our behavior
we're robbed of something else the
principle of free will crucial to
democratic liberty
we call on all states and corporations
to respect these rights we call on all
citizens to stand up and defend these
rights we call on the united nations to
acknowledge the central importance of
protecting civil rights in the digital
age and to create an international bill
of digital rights we call on governments
to sign and adhere to such a convention
so that's pretty heady stuff isn't it uh
very dramatic very exciting especially
the the all caps we demand we call on
and notice who they're they're talking
to um they're demanding a right a set of
rights actually then they are calling on
all states and corporations calling on
all citizens calling on the united
nations calling on governments so this
is a this is a a program this is this is
a whole
set of ideas wrapped up here and if this
were to be followed it would be it would
make some pretty interesting changes now
wouldn't it
and
you can ask yourself what is the effect
of this going to be i want to put those
questions off until the end
what i want to focus on now
are
really
four main things i want to talk about
some of the key players in these
these shifting
balance of power
kind of scrabbling around things that
this this manifesto represents that the
the open letter represents and what it
means for the rest of us little people
out there
then i want to talk about some of the
the key issues that are involved in
information gathering and i just want to
touch on them i'm not going to spend a
lot of time on them then i want to look
very carefully at this manifesto and
some of its claims and some of its
assumptions
here's a little bit of you know
foreshadowing i disagree with with quite
a few of them
uh for various reasons and and i'll talk
about that and then i want to point out
some tensions and paradoxes involved in
taking these sort of stands
and ultimately then i'll give my own
kind of pessimistic take on on all of
this
at the very end
so
who are the key players
in
information gathering and
talking about the technosphere
and about our lives
well you know let's remind ourselves
just how wide the technosphere goes the
internet is now an integral part
of
the way we do business
the way our workplaces are are set up
and situated
the way our educational institutions
take place i mean just for example my
face to face classes a good portion of
the class is actually in a course
management system and students
message me and email me within that or
within the schools network
pretty much every day
our grades are are put online um there's
a lot of things that have been turned
around so economy education politics is
in large part uh
connected up with the internet i mean we
saw some massive transformations in
recent political campaigns and just
think about the arguments that go on on
twitter or facebook between uh people of
different political orientations and
parties
it goes further than that
our personal lives in general are
you know to some degree mediated in one
way or another by the internet
and we could go on and on and on and
things get bigger and bigger and bigger
we sell books on the internet we read
books on the internet um it has become
well you know we consult our travel
schedules
things that are not electronic
are
in large respect
sucked into this digital world that we
we live in for better or for worse
so who are the key players well a lot of
the key players are the same ones that
that were big players
before the internet
governments
states
corporations
what we call the fourth estate you know
the the media
educational institutions other forms of
non-governmental
organizations that don't actually fit
into that and then you know there's this
broad swath of the people at least you
know if we're talking about some sort of
democratic society
and
who are the key players
let's think about governments for a
moment because that's who these these
two documents are aimed at primarily at
governments so what is a government you
have at least in a democracy some sort
of elected body and you know we have we
have the three branches of government
only
two of which are actually elected uh in
some states of course judges may be
elected uh or may be appointed but i'm
talking about federal because you know
the nsa is not a state organization it's
a federal organization for the united
states
so
there is the obama administration
previously there was the bush
administration previous to that there
was the clinton administration
we've had a lot of uh continuity in
these because they've been
two-term presidents
and when you elect a president you don't
just elect a president or a vice
president you elect an entire cabinet
that comes along with them
you're electing certain realignments in
in political power that are taking place
in the house and the senate as well and
we have congress you know
uh the the legislative branch we have uh
the two houses
and those are elected officials so we
have that portion of government over
here that's that those are the ones that
are sort of
directly responsible to the people i
understand there's all sorts of problems
in saying that because in a lot of cases
you know you probably if you're an
american you live in districts which are
not actually competitive districts or
you live in states like i do
where new york is almost always going to
vote democrat so you know you wonder
what's the point in actually casting a
vote
but
they are at least in theory
elected responsible responsive that's
that's integral to democracy
but government includes a lot of other
stuff as well
particularly you know the executive
branch all these agencies have tons and
tons of people who are working for the
government and were never elected to
anything
and may be working for the government
throughout their entire life government
jobs are you know pretty
pretty uh
safe jobs in in many respects once
you've got them they're hard to to lose
uh unless you're an appointed official
and so at the very tops you know the top
brackets those people are responsible to
the people who are responsible to
the general american public
but they're pretty insulated
and as we go further and further down in
these people are not accountable to
the american people
these persons let's say are not
accountable to the american people in
general
the average nsa worker
is uh somebody with a g rating
and
you're never gonna know who they are
unless you know something comes to life
or one of them you know defects like
like snowden did
um and you're not going to know what
they're up to and as a matter of fact
most of the people in the executive or
legislative branch are not going to know
what they're up to these government
agencies often take on a life of their
own and they develop an ethos and you
can talk about you know the difference
between
the state department and
the intelligence community on certain
things um just for you know one example
of a historical example of how
how much effects this can have
i don't remember whose book it came up
in but they're talking about george bush
and the problems that he had getting the
cia to actually
do what they were supposed to do
in information gathering and analysis
and all that
and it wasn't just that
you know they were providing purely
objective data and the bush
administration was cooking it
one index of this if you went out in the
parking lot you could see an ocean of
cars
with bumper stickers
of his opponents
now you know
that an agency that has its own sort of
momentum and inertia and ways of doing
things that's staffed by
people hostile to the new
administration is going to drag its
heels and
raise all sorts of difficulties that
don't need to to be raised and they're
not going to streamline or smooth things
out as they would if the person who they
wanted to win
would have won
in that case it was gore that was being
talked about but this is just one
example among many and we could pick
others you know where democrats are
getting the shaft as well my point is
in addressing something to the
governments are you talking to the the
elected officials or are you talking to
these non-elected
administrative bureaucratic structures
full of people who are doing their jobs
motivated by all sorts of interests and
concerns that may not be reflective at
all of the administration let alone of
the people the administration is
supposed to be
protecting and representing
so that's one set then you have
corporations and it's interesting to see
that in this particular declaration they
do target the corporations at the very
same time that these corporations are
telling the government hey you need to
ease up on this this spying and
information gathering
because the corporations themselves
they've been doing a lot of of this
information gathering
even before the government asked them to
do it
and the only reason why the government
can actually expect all this cooperation
and information from them is because
they are gathering and storing that
information in the first place
and to what ends again is it is it the
stuff that's going to benefit the the
little people well not necessarily
google has its own designs its own
motives its own imperatives they make
decisions that are quite often
not transparent
themselves
same thing goes for apple same thing
goes for microsoft
there really are no good guys
there are only
companies that allow good things to
happen but there are no genuine good
guys among these top tier companies
what about opinion formers
it's interesting to see that you know
what i've got linked to is in large part
from the guardian
the guardian is a newspaper they are a
media outlet they're always they're
involved in information gathering as
well but of a different sort
and
they also want to know about their
readership they also provide forums for
people to discuss things and to work
things out
and then let's think about these writers
these writers are not just ordinary
people
they are what we call opinion formers
you know to a certain extent i'm an
opinion former in part because of the
youtube channel and in part because i'm
a college professor so i get to shape
young minds uh at least if they pay
attention to me right
but i'm a pretty low level
uh one in the food chain as far as
that's concerned there's a lot of people
who are way way above me you could write
a self-help book and have a hell of a
lot more influence than i do
and um these novelists and playwrights
and god knows what else they're they're
taking a principled stand themselves but
are they representing us
i don't feel that they represent us i
don't even know who half of these people
let's not even say half i don't know who
95 of these people are
and i'm not sure what sort of process
they use to arrive at this declaration
there's a lot of opacity all around and
so i don't think that we want to you
know set up a narrative this is why i'm
going through all this i don't think we
want to set up narratives where there's
people wearing white hats and people
wearing black hats in this the situation
is more complex
now let's think about key issues
involved in information gathering
are people gathering information in part
if you're your company you want
information about customers so that's
why they give you these things that go
on your keychains and you know you scan
them in at cvs for example so you can
get some cvs bucks and coupons and what
they're doing is they're tracking your
buying habits
and the same thing is going on for the
social networks that you're involved in
the same thing is going on
for
you know
if people are tracking emails for for
subject lines and emails
um we you know there's stories that the
nsa actually
engaged in some spying on americans
gaming habits
um
there's there's there's a wide range of
gap information gathering going on some
of it is is purely about the profit
motive and about trying to provide
a more tailored what they call intuitive
uh approach to customers or to potential
customers towards consumers
whereas providing people what what they
what google thinks that they want or
apple thinks that they want i mean if
you go into itunes
and you look at the these suggestions
for the music that that is based on
what it is that you've purchased before
what else they know that you've
you've looked at or sampled
it's kind of funny because if it doesn't
predict very well then then we're kind
of irritated with it and if it does
predict very well then we're suspicious
of it
um
but that's that's
that's an issue we'll come back to what
are some other bigger issues well
security
you know we are actually uh en engaged
in a
like it or not a war on terror and it
may be very different than how the
narrative of it has been framed but
there are people out there who are
engaged in all sorts of different
activities that are hostile to
the kind of uh
western
modern liberal democracies consumer
cultures that we we live in that that um
they're using the technosphere sort of
against some of its
its uh
key components
um and they could be coming from all
over the the spectrum but there you know
there are some criminal activities there
are terrorist activities um there are
legitimate uses for gathering data there
is spying going on by foreign
governments um in you know the the
realms of other foreign governments i
would not be surprised to find out that
the nsa and the cia are involved in
using information not only to you know
track al qaeda
but also to keep tabs on chinese
activities here in the united states
i wouldn't be surprised either to find
out that the chinese intelligence
services are doing the same things with
respect to american penetration and
spying within china that's part of what
goes on
but that is that is an important issue
is security being provided
are we preventing you know terrorist
attacks by by monitoring chatter
um another big issue is the privacy of
users
where does that privacy begin and end
and what are the grounds of it i don't
think that we should ever assume
something like an absolute right of
privacy that we never have to justify
i think it's important to justify why
privacy matters
and because that helps us figure out
what misuse of the data actually
consists of
another big issue is ownership of
information
who actually owns information that is
generated
uh that is elicited that is stored
who does that really belong to does it
belong just to the originator the person
who gave a let's think about a facebook
like
does that does my like belong to me
or does it belong to facebook or does it
belong you know to to all sorts of
entities maybe our understanding of
property
needs to be
rethought with respect to intellectual
property in the internet
another big issue is uh the kind of
paranoia and panopticon effect that
being under surveillance produces and
that's something that they talk about in
the manifesto so good segue let's now
talk about this manifesto and some of
its claims and assumptions
so
let me signal
right off the bat one thing i'm in
complete agreement with when it comes to
this manifesto and these writers
in the point where they say surveillance
makes the individual transparent
while the state and corporation operate
in secret as we have seen this power is
being systematically abused i think
that's dead-on
i think that um
the right surveillance does make the
individual transparent at least to the
extent that an individual can be made
transparent
well it um allows those who are actually
engaging in the surveillance the state
and the corporation they get to operate
in secret
even if we you know sort of peel it back
parts of the state parts of the
corporation even when there's some
transparency are operating the secret
and we do know that there are systematic
abuses of this going on how far they
extend that's an epistemological
question that is very difficult to
answer
but that's where i agree with this this
manifesto
you notice there's a lot of other points
to it
i i tend to be a little bit skeptical
uh
ranging from a little bit skeptical to
totally confused bemused
and in opposition to some of the other
points
so let's talk first about their rhetoric
about democracy so they say the basic
pillar of democracy is the inviolable
integrity of the individual
they don't actually mean democracy there
what they mean is what we call liberal
democracy which doesn't have to do with
liberal conservative both of them are
actually liberal in that extent
recognizing that there are inviolable
rights of an individual that is not
inherent to democracy that's inherent to
the liberal
uh political tradition there are other
traditions that do
talk about this that do respect it
even even in you know
actual liberal democracies this is not a
principle that's a hundred percent
observed but it is at least an ideal
human integrity extends beyond the
physical body okay i can go along with
that
in their thoughts and personal
environments and communications all
humans have the right to remain
unobserved and unmolested
we'll come back to that in a moment
thoughts absolutely
i i have no problem with saying there
should be a certain realm in which you
get to have
nobody else intruding and you get to
think and you don't have to be a
cartesian to see a space for that sort
of thing as being a
good
a good development
but our personal environments when i'm
interacting with somebody else on on
facebook or via email
it's not just my personal environment is
it i'm not i'm not the solipsistic
center of the universe
dropping down the curtain of you know
secrecy
on everything that i engage in
all those other people and the
commitments that they make or this you
know stupid false steps that they make
those have to do with my
information
let's come back to democracy now so
they say
that a society under surveillance is no
longer a democracy well i guess when
there are you know very few democracies
i don't like this rhetoric this all or
nothing rhetoric if you want to talk
about democracy
then focus on what democracy really
means which is getting to vote getting
to hold office getting to participate in
deliberation
it doesn't have to do
um so much with not getting observed as
far as i can see that that's kind of
tangential to this
a society under surveillance is no
longer democracy that could be the case
but that case needs to be made it's not
self-evident by itself that surveillance
automatically rules this out
and then they say to maintain any
validity our democratic rights must
apply in virtual as well as real space
yeah that that makes some sense but
notice the virtual must be dependent
upon the real i think
um so i i'm kind of concerned with their
sloppy use of the notion of democracy i
think that's that that's just sort of a
emotional appeal
and
i i just think that's a bad idea
in thoughts and personal environments we
have a right to remain unobserved and
unmolested
that unobserved and unmolested
are they the same thing
unmolested untroubled not being
interfered with
as opposed to unobserved
sounds to me
like if i'm putting information out
there
and i'm engaging in a social network
with other people
it's probably you know it's one thing to
say that i shouldn't be silenced
nobody should be able to to make me
unable to post on my own stuff
but if i do post
why should i be unobserved where did my
right to be unobserved come from
does it i can only be observed by the
people that i
choose to be involved with
it's not really the way that social
networks work
there you know history is is rife with
examples of people whose
unintended messages got out and then you
know proved ruinous to them
um
i'm not sure that that
a person always has a right to be
unobserved in the way that they're
talking about
they say that survival that surveillance
violates the private sphere it
compromises the freedom of thought and
opinion and i i do see some validity to
this
if you know that you're being watched
and you're afraid that they're going to
be bad consequences from
uh the sort of things that you say
you're probably more likely to keep it
under wraps
but the same thing goes you know i mean
think about a workplace
there are some things that you probably
shouldn't say in a work email
there are some things that you shouldn't
say in the office if you want to keep
your job
do you get to say well no that's purely
private space
once i start communicating i mean the
very notion of communication means
sharing of information
and you could say well what about the
private sphere you know your friends
your family your colleagues not not you
know work related things but
but other sorts of matters
um
i should be free say to to express
whatever sort of views i have however
unorthodox or unsavory they may be
without encountering any sort of
repercussions
um
you know it depends on where we draw the
line for the private sphere
and that's an open question that's not
something i think you can just take for
granted
mass surveillance treats every citizen
as a potential suspect it overturns the
presumption of innocence
again i'm not sure that that's the case
i think this is one of those those uh
instances where they're sort of defining
their opponents into a box
if surveillance is something you only
get to do when somebody is suspected of
something
then the presumption of innocence is
already gone
but is that really the case for for
surveillance is that what's going on
with mass surveillance
are they presuming all of us guilty
until proven otherwise i don't think
it's actually in that framework
i don't think that this framework is
actually very helpful even if we
introduce like you know the the scotch
three possible you know
guilty innocent not proven guilty thing
i don't think that even captures it
adequately what's going on in
surveillance
are they really assuming everybody to be
guilty until they're proven innocent
well then everybody would be in prison
these legal categories are not
particularly helpful for sorting this
out
um here's the most interesting thing the
second actually most interesting thing
that they say
surveillance is theft
surveillance is theft it is
what is that it is stealing from another
person
depriving them of what it is that they
they previously had
data belongs to us it's not public
property
now who i call on my phone
uh that does belong to me that's
information that i generated
it also belongs to my phone provider if
i'm involved in some sort of
legal issue the police can acquire that
as well they pull phone records all the
time
what it is that i say in the
conversation
is that
solely mine alone no because it also
belongs to the other party in the
conversation
can it be recorded and retransmitted
that really depends a lot on state laws
um
but in general
either party could could record it and
and be right to do so
there may be some cases where you have
to actually inform somebody of that
but you know i'm not sure that
surveillance really is theft or that
it's helpful to use this rhetoric of
property rights and theft and the
private
so again i'm i'm very skeptical of that
now here we get to the most interesting
thing
when surveillance is used to predict our
behavior we are robbed of something else
the principle of free will crucial to
democratic liberty
now is that true
because if so
that's a pretty
amazing metaphysical claim
we can be deprived of free will merely
by being observed
well no not just merely by being
observed by somebody actually observing
us and paying attention to what we do
to the extent that they can make
predictions whether the predictions are
actually true or false that they can
make some sort of
reasonable or reliable predictions
so when amazon is suggesting to me
based on my previous purchases that i
might like this other book or they're
actually
not even looking at what i buy and
they're saying you know customers who
purchase this book tended to also like
this book they're robbing me of my free
will
that's ludicrous
if that's that's what free will is for
you you don't really have free will
lionel trilling had this this great
discussion of free will in uh sincerity
and authenticity
where he suggested that in the modern
world
perhaps some people don't actually
develop the will to the extent that
other people do that there's some sort
of you know lack of
of
proper
training or encouragement or development
and that you know the society itself
could play a role in that
and this sounds an awful lot
like
what a world full of people like that
would be
uh would be like
and
i i just you know to me when i when i
read something like this we are robbed
of the principle of free will crucial to
democratic liberty by having predictions
made about us
that doesn't that doesn't really make
any sense
what i want to try to understand is how
they arrived at this and again i'm
prevented from doing that by the fact
that they didn't show their work
they're not transparent
they're just throwing a bunch of slogans
out there
and
are we being invited into the
conversation with these opinion formers
these you know elites
uh who
presumably matter more than we do
are they really taking our side against
the nefarious government and
corporations
or are they just you know one more set
of bastards
trying to push their stuff onto us and
get us to see things their way that's
that's the way i tend to to look at it
um so let me let me now talk about a few
of the paradoxes involved in this so
here's the biggest paradox
people who are upset about surveillance
and i'm actually one of them because i i
think that some abuses have taken place
and i'm pretty sure some abuses are
continuing to take place
there's this wanting to derive
benefits from the technosphere from the
the networks that we're involved in from
the intuitive software from all these
technological innovations
and benefits as well from the government
like you know not getting blown up or
not getting
threatened routinely you know social
order
being able to rely on logistics networks
actually functioning
all those sorts of things
we want to derive the benefits from it
and we're perfectly fine with our
information going out there into
the public sphere
or the you know
less public but but some you know still
not completely private sphere of the
economy provided we get the results that
we want out of it
it's a devil's bargain though because if
you're going to do that if you're going
to have amazon and google and microsoft
actually figure out what it is that you
you want you like and make suggestions
to you
then um
you're gonna have to let them gather
information about you and store that
information and use algorithms to sort
through it
and if you want the government to be
able to
listen to some people's you know phone
conversations
or you know track
words within emails or look for flags or
things along those lines
well you can't be completely selective
about it
you can't establish
maps
that have a million different we don't
know what's here
blocks
um
and everybody seems to to want a lack of
transparency for everybody else
but they want to preserve complete
opacity for themselves so this is the
second paradox not only is there is a
sort of weird paradox about we want the
benefits but none of the costs
we want complete transparency for
everybody else
and we want to be completely opaque
ourselves we want to have complete
control over our own data we want it to
be we want other people
other people's access to our information
be subject to our choice to our decision
making that just can't work
i'm not saying that the system that we
have is is a good one or
even a safe one but what you know that
sort of proposal of i'm gonna get to
decide only what information anybody
else can get get about me
that's crazy that can't possibly work
that cannot be
even generalized let alone universalized
it can't be made into a governing
practice
we have to figure out where does the
personnel actually end and i don't think
that we have good answers for this
question yet particularly when it comes
to the the internet
we have you know issues about how do you
actually enforce law
and not just law but that that deeper
structure of order that's required to
keep everything flowing
more or less smoothly for so that we can
enjoy the kind of lifestyle that we do
in fact want to have
so so badly that is one of the very
few
positive compensations of the the
infiltration of the technosphere into
just about every walk of life
um
you know another question that or
another problem that all of this raises
is they they're appealing to citizens
and they're saying we call on all
citizens to stand up and defend these
rights
how the hell is that supposed to happen
more petitions
armed resistance
something in between organization of a
new political party
there's no positive proposal in here
it's just sort of left to us to figure
out
and i gotta tell you the last thing i
actually
feel like i need
is
500 more uh people who i don't know but
are considered to be more important than
me telling me what to do
you know
we've already got enough of them already
in the politicians and the business
people and the other opinion formers
um
now i'm going to give you my sort of
super pessimistic uh
sum up of all this
it's so pessimistic that it actually
becomes quite comic and my pessimism
turns into a type of
optimism
um
i think there's there's normative issues
involved here about what should go on
and then there's you know more factual
or predictive or prudential issues about
well what should we expect to be the
case
i'm really out to see with respect to
the normative issues i don't have a lot
of positive suggestions to give all i
can say is sort of a pox on all their
houses
and i don't i don't really trust any of
these these uh these groups but i'm
stuck with all of them and i'm not sure
where the dividing line should be drawn
on these things i need to do a lot of a
lot more thinking about this stuff i'm
sure there's a lot smarter people who
have proposals
about these things i can tell you this
this though any sort of simplistic
solution to this is probably going to be
wrong
now
i think it's probably
prudent to expect that information is
being gathered and stored
pretty much any time that it can be
and that somebody's buying and selling
or trading or or demanding this
information at one point or another
that's the pessimist in me
that pessimism flows over
into the people who are actually
gathering and storing and doing things
you know interpreting this information
as well
i think that
people at google
are a lot dumber than we are led to
expect that they show occasional moments
of brilliance
and
that there's quite a few people there
who are bright but also stupid at the
same time i'm willing to bet that's the
case for just about every
big corporation that we look at
if you look at just you know the updates
that they release you know apple can't
release a decent update of
video software that doesn't
piss off
all the apple users because new features
have been or older features have been
you know taken out or made more
difficult to use
that's a sign of people who actually in
a certain respect can be trusted with
information because they're too dumb to
actually
really dig into it and figure out what
to do with it
um they'll misuse it they'll abuse it
and the same thing goes for the nsa i'm
sure that these are not all
you know super brilliant brain trust
kids processing all this information you
know ferreting into our our very mode of
life
i'm sure that quite a few of them are
bored are missing things are not paying
attention to what's going on computer
algo algorithms
can spot things but computers are
quite dumb in many respects so my i
don't need to belabor this point my
pessimism extends to to those who are
actually gathering and doing things with
the information
um sometimes underhandedly sometimes
above the board sometimes a mixture of
both
i don't think
i'm so pessimistic about this whole
thing but i think that they won't in
many cases actually be able to do very
much with with the information that they
acquire that the veniality and you know
short-sightedness and stupidity that
that's inherent to the human condition
will
keep them from actually being able to to
do as many bad things as they possibly
could with it
um
so there's my my take on the situation i
close with that
and like i said there's a lot more to be
said about this but i'll have to talk
about some of the other
issues involved in later videos